[Musik]
münchen
ey leute kabinetts willkommen beim neuen
video auf jeden fall ich bin drauf
gestand heute geht's nach salzburg ich
bin gerade auf 1011 an
wir müssen jetzt nach köln zum flughafen
und von da aus geht es los ich habe
gerade noch ein frühstück und vielleicht
noch ein video was reinkommt muss man
sich auf jeden fall noch anschauen der
block und der sonntag aber schon statt
von freitag an leute ich will eigentlich
gar nicht eingeladen als sofort los muss
nicht gleich v3 so leute wirkungslos das
ding ist
wir fahren nicht mit zug und auto und
das ding ist seinen führerschein
verloren deswegen lass mich dein auto
fahren also ich bin auf jeden fall gute
für den verloren hat okay nicht was
hinter uns vielleicht doch etwas geht
wir sind jetzt weg nachteil das ding ist
das wetter jetzt total scheiße aber in
österreich um so besser sein ist oft
letzten platz ein video
weil es muss ein video online schnell
war habe ich auf jeden fall box online
ich kann ja schlecht schreiben um zu
konsumieren weil sie sonst nur zu
verpassen so heftig auf jetzt 30 auf
jeden fall schon 15 uhr mesz nach
einzigen respekt gepäck abgeben und dann
müsste auch die ganz andere seite dass
wir so heftig war auch erst direkt nicht
die ganze zeit war auch bei der live
stream heute übrigens zum ersten mal
bisschen nervös sterbe gleich heute wenn
manche vertragen dass so manches aber
selbst die kosten beim ersten 50 der
merlins bisschen nervös ich schon oder
du bist du nie geflogen war jahrelang
nur in deutschland einfach nicht schon
eine verspätung startete hat mein video
hof direkt vor den toiletten also
tatsächlich nein ich nicht raus ausrede
sein
[Musik]
ich werde diese karte studieren
immerhin ehrlichkeit ansprechen sap ist
lang vor angriff richtige zeit dass zum
schluss immer die ganz einfach schlucken
[Musik]
balda tun hat
leider so
kleiner tipp
aber kleine
[Musik]
wehrleiter etwa berge
range rover range rover und spaß sagt es
so sagen ich weiß ganzes los ist es voll
bedeckt aber locker 50 grad sein 20
so leute bin ich irgendwann salzburg und
begeistert auf jeden fall sehr schöne
gegend und ich habe keine ahnung wo er
gleich in seiner rüstung sein soll aber
hier soll ein freund warst du glaubst
nicht dass dieses weist die tendenz
wir laufen jetzt schon gefühlte
vollständig salzburg sie meinte mitten
in zehn minuten da also wenn der bürger
jetzt gut bei mir könnte mir vorstellen
hier zu wenig zu sein
firma star ist schon schön
ende
ein schöner
[Musik]
omega rutscht immer weiter runter
natürlich auch dort würden sich nur kurz
hinsetzen vier einzeln so leute was geht
guten morgen wir sind jetzt hier bei der
dult messe in salzburg regeneration
hintereingang weil wir das finden dann
freue ich mich heute ein paar treppen
wirklich ganz cool nehmt euch natürlich
weiterhin mit und wer kommt mal was
passiert das würdet ihr wurden im
flieger als abgenommen als wirklich was
das schlimmste zeit wachse trinkt reicht
ganzen körper meine hartwig sind wir
sehen uns gleich florian irgendwie hier
n2 aber dass es fünf und zwei
hallo
[Musik]
werden
juli
hey leute ich werde eine kleine aber ich
war bei kosten und renditen der beste
was los
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so deute die dokumente den vorbei war
auf jeden fall hätte auf jeden fall
gefallen war hat sofort von ihr auf dem
flughafen geht wieder nach haus
nachteilen die mega mega fertig aber mal
sehen was noch passiert ich glaube ich
bin noch nicht wieder haben wir 35 wir
sind jetzt hier noch in salzburg im
hangar-7 oder so wir sind auf jeden fall
mega viele sachen von red bull zum
beispiel mit diesen dingen ist felix
baumgartner irgendwie ausland zu suchen
da will ich mich auch mal reinsetzen da
kann man sich einfach hinlegen sieht
alles und wer da oben fliegt sie gestört
ich habe übrigens kann leicht autos
haben 805.000 kostenrisiko
[Musik]
drei leute wurden hat einfach von im
ganzen zu kaufen wollen wir ausgerufen
und die ganzen namen allem das glas weil
wir zu spät sind aber wenn's gar nicht
recht
[Musik]
so leute was geht herzlich willkommen
zurück in köln ich bin jetzt mal
gespannt die schöne für die south park
die gefahr müssen damit pech haben
einfach 60 euro für einen tag also halt
lieber vielen franzosen ich würde sagen
ich beende sind okay ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn er mehr davon sehen
vor dass auf jeden fall jetzt nach oben
da und es macht spaß durch mitzunehmen
und ganz griechenland schneiden sie
kaufen falls das wetter abgesehen und
parteien